ça fait un peu beaucoup de monde
ils ont l'air un peu méchant
qu'est-ce que c'est que ces bonhommes
verts ça doit être des gars déguisés qui
amusent les gens dans la rue des
mascottes ou alors des militants écolos
on dirait plutôt des mini Shrek en plus
moche ça va aller on s'est préparé à ça
toute notre vie oui sauf qu'on sait
jamais battu pour de vrai et
je tends comment ça se fait que j'ai
qu'un bateau l'atmosphère avec une
blague je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
bon moment trop de blabla toutes les
nuits je rêve de me bastonner rafle avec
la violence il faut que tu consultes
mais c'est pas un problème
[Musique]
notre entrée en scène était vraiment
pourrie
peut-être que si on leur raconte le
récit tragique de notre vie ils seront
émus massacrer
[Musique]
tu prends cette gauche moi je prends
cette
gauche l'autre gauche
vous approchez pas j'ai un gros bateau
en bois
tu veux crever
tu me cherches Bordeaux
même pas mal
calme-toi doucement
je rêve où il fait des Tokyo Drift
[Musique]
je suis le meilleur
vous avez vu ça
[Musique]